today I learned it since 2010 New
Yorkers have been complaining more I'm
Rita my google developer advocate join
me now as I explore the trends from the
past six years New York City 311 calls
with bigquery most complained types have
seen an increase but they're not
consistently distributed and many
categories have actually seen a decrease
the most significant complaint increases
are related to cars noise and garbage
the most striking are those related to
parked cars frankly I'm amazed anyone
even tries to park in New York City
illegal parking complaints are up over
four hundred percent representing nearly
a hundred thousand additional calls that
by itself is almost a third of the total
increase in 2 2010 block driveways and
derelict vehicles represent another
hundred thousand extra call so it's
clear that people just don't know where
to lead their cars note that there is
also a sharp increase in broken parking
meter complaints so some people at least
are trying to do the right thing noise
complaints have always accounted for the
most 311 calls they have now more than
doubled since 2010 with over 200,000
additional calls in 2016 which
represents nearly eighteen percent of
all calls there's also a notable
increases in complaints about homeless
encampments dirty sidewalks and mist
garbage pickups and are possibly not
unrelated increase in rat sightings
thankfully trend hasn't been entirely
one way with many complaint type seeing
significant decreases the city walls are
looking cleaner with complaints about
graffiti and illegal posturing both down
and illegal posting specifically down
nearly eighty percent broken street
lights and salty traffic signals of both
down around fifty percent possibly
related to the gradual introduction of
LEDs and street repairs seem to be
failing far less often we can also see
that each borough has evolved in its own
way here I'm looking at the complaint
types that have increased or decreased a
significantly different rate in one
Barra compared to the others in Brooklyn
for example derelict vehicle complaints
are more than sixty percent higher than
the other boroughs Manhattan saw the
largest growth and complaints and as you
can see really draw some of the
categories with the biggest increases
particularly for noise
illegal parking it also went against the
trend for graffiti street cabins and
faulty pedestrian signals getting worse
where the other boroughs all for an
improvement in the Bronx complaints
about loud music on the street and
coming from cars have grown it around
twice the rate of the other bars
meanwhile in Queens complains about poor
three conditions including potholes and
cracked roads up ten percent against a
five percent downwards trend everywhere
else finally in Staten Island the alleys
or even dirtier and broken street lights
are up against the trend remember that
in every case here we're measuring the
change in the number of complaints it
expected increasing complaints to
correlate with more problems but it's
possible that people are just
complaining more I've cherry-picked what
I thought were the most interesting
trends but they are by no means
comprehensive as always you'll first
terabyte the processing each month is
free so i invite you to open up the
query and do your own trend
investigations on this and all our other
public data sets and share your results
with our seasons today I learned with
bigquery hashtag and as always subscribe
to our channel and follow our blog to
learn something new every week would be
clear